hi and thanks for checking in I'm
Anthony Mason and we're here in the CBS
this morning Toyota greenroom with
author Mitch Albom his best-selling book
the five people you need in heaven has
Touch readers lives for 15 years it
tells the story of Eddie a maintenance
worker in an amusement park who dies
after his saving a girl named Annie
albums new novel the next person you
meet in heaven is a sequel to that
popular story it follows a me as an
adult and introduces us to the five
people she meets in heaven Mitch Albom
good to see you hi thanks for being here
I know you've you've talked about this a
little bit already out on tour that that
people were asking you for years to
write a sequel for this book yeah of all
the books that I've written this is
probably one I've heard the most about
as you mentioned you know Eddie dies
goes to have' meets five people but it
is described in that book as the first
stage of heaven right so of course
everybody will watch the second stage of
it and so you know that combined with
people asking what happened to Annie did
she grow up and I always thought that
that would be interesting what happens
if you grow up knowing that your life is
only going on because somebody else's is
gone yeah so it seemed after 15 years
and I've had have been on my mind anyhow
for you know losses in my life in the
last few years I love well this was a
good time to do it did you have when you
wrote the when you wrote the first book
did you have answers to those questions
no really that's an interesting question
when I wrote the first but first I was
15 years younger and what I was really
trying to do with the first book was
write a book that showed people who like
my uncle thought they were nobodies
mm-hmm actually were wrong that
everybody is somebody everybody touches
somebody's life do you have no idea and
so Eddie is the quintessential nobody he
thinks he you know he's wasted his whole
life he's working fixing rides and an
amusement park what kind of job is that
for a grown man when he gets to heaven
he finds out that you know towards the
end that when he was in the war he
killed a little girl accidentally he
burned a hut and she was inside of it
and so this life of being at an
amusement park
keeping rides safe for children was
actually as form of penance for what he
had done to this so so there was a
balance to it all yeah so
this book Annie doesn't remember the
accident she blacks it all out it's all
one of those traumatic things she only
remembers going in the morning and then
coming home and something everything was
different right and she is haunted by
the idea that everything she does is a
mistake not understanding that well of
course that was like the biggest mistake
she ran the wrong direction he had to
save her he dies as a result right so
the point of this book is similarly to
the first one no there's not
life is not a mistake the things that
you do are not mistakes we just don't
realize perhaps what they're going to
lead to or what right they can allow us
to do by doing wrong the first time
around and that was kind of the overall
message of this how full a picture did
you have of Annie going into this book
less than Andy because edit was based on
a real person yeah and he was my uncle
Addie who was 83 grizzled war vet he
actually had a near-death experience
which inspired this whole kind of
concept when he was in open-heart
surgery he said that he died and they
said that he died and he came out of his
body and kind of rose up above the table
and was looking down and then he said he
saw all his dead relatives waiting for
him at the edge of course we were asking
what you do uncle and you know he was a
salty old guy said do like told him get
the hell out I'm not ready for anything
and and then he went back into his body
I think he scared them back into heaven
and yeah you know he lived a little
while longer but to me that was always
the idea of what happens when you go to
heaven because he was I mean you trust
your relatives right I mean there are
lots of books out there about the white
light and all that but when your uncle
tells you yeah you believe it Joe in
there
yeah he's been there briefly but been
there and so I thought okay this is
really what happens but what if they're
not all your relatives what if they're
just people who some maybe your
relatives as in this book and he's your
mother again yeah but some may just be
passerby people that you you know spent
five minutes with and you change their
life and they changed yours forever and
I really believe that we have that
effect on it you have I mean you've had
six number one consecutive number one
bestsellers going back to Tuesdays with
Maurey you have you have a lot of fans
who come maybe with some expectations
and I'm wondering when you sit down to
write a book like this if you feel that
in any way sure I'm unimaginative does
in some regard
in a small way for example Tuesdays with
Maurey never had a curse word in it and
when I went to write my next book by the
time I got to write it to amore had very
accidentally because it was supposed to
be a tiny little book right had become
this really widely read book and I
remember I put some curse words in the
novel that I was writing and I got back
no no you can't do that and you know and
I never have since I mean you know
there's no sex scenes there's no curse
words
yeah there's certain expectations from
your audience yeah but really it's not a
I'm not pigeon holed because I am
writing what I am interested in and it
also happens that's what they're
interested in I don't think people would
come to me for a science fiction novel
about outer space but I'm not really
interested in writing the science
fiction about outer space I'm interested
in life and and it's different meanings
and and the observations we have about
it and I just try to find interesting
ways to tell the story you you alluded
to this earlier but in the end you wrote
this book in part to process some of
your own personal grace mm-hmm well I
lost my mother my father and a little
girl that we were raising as her
daughter I have an orphanage in Haiti
that I operate and she was one of our 47
kids she developed a brain tumor came up
to live with us as we traveled the world
trying to keep her alive you dedicate
the book to her I do because I think
children really teach you they teach you
I think the most significant thing they
teach you is that life is a lot better
when you're living it for someone else
than just for yourself and that's what I
think the concept of family really is
based on and for two years my wife and I
we did not have children of our own even
though we got 47 kids in Haiti right
really had that family thing with her
and you know I thought so much about
loss and it's so easy to get lost in the
agony of loss yes so there's a moment in
the book which is directly related to
chica and our little girls passing one
of the characters I won't say who does
this thing with pipe cleaners to Annie
because pipe cleaners play a role in the
book and he takes there were five pipe
cleaners he takes one and he makes a
little heart perfect it's small and he
says you see this this is the heart
we're born with and then he takes the
other four and he makes his big heart
with line
across it and everything like that but
it's biggest as you see this this is the
heart we die with and she says but it's
all lined it's all broken he says that's
right many times and she says so that's
what ruins it he says no that's what
makes it whole and that's the way I have
had to come to learn to live with loss
and I think you know everybody does that
we have to recognize it yes we get these
scars on our heart but that's also what
makes living rich and makes us
appreciate the people we still have and
the things we still have to do if you
didn't have the threat of ever losing
anything you wouldn't know how precious
it was did the book proof the writing
approved therapeutic in that way it did
I did I'm actually yeah I'm actually
working on a book now about Chico which
is also very therapeutic and the
philosophy that I have is we didn't lose
a child we were given one mm-hmm and
throughout the next person you meet in
heaven that's kind of the idea too that
you keep thinking you make mistakes
Annie yeah but you were given an
opportunity you were given a chance if
she was saved for example by Eddie she
becomes a nurse yeah why why'd you
become a nurse opportunity to save other
people make up for the life that you
were treated we never even realized what
might be at work you know moving us
around on the board I want to ask you
one last thing because you wrote a
lovely column last week about about
about someone who gave you a lot of
support who probably didn't even realize
it yeah Dave Anderson Newark Times
columnist yeah lost yeah and and you
point out in that column he probably
doesn't even know what he did for
exactly changed my life I'm so glad you
brought that up because it's exactly the
case I was a starving musician here in
New York yeah I was looking for money I
was working as a freelance writer for a
weekly shopper magazine it just had TV
listings but what but the editor liked
to have like a celebrity on the cover so
once a week they were profile of
celebrity I got assigned for $50.00 Dave
Anderson the vine columnist for The New
York Times he actually met me for lunch
I mean I don't know why he even answered
the phone yes but he met me for lunch in
a new area 57th Street and Broadway yeah
he was there before me I bumbled through
all these questions about sports writing
at one point he said I think you're
making more of this job than inactions
was like but I was so impressed with him
and and I ended up leave I remember
going down to the subway and thinking I
wouldn't mind being like him yeah
kind of a cool job and eventually I
became a sports writer years later ran
into him and and he looked at me said in
your ear and and he said I guess I
couldn't talk you out of it huh yeah now
he did he had no idea that that lunch
was gonna do that and I had no idea but
look at how that one little bump changed
my life all that way and you know in
that conceit Dave will be one of the
people I mean in heaven but yes he
changed my life though I think we all do
that to one another we recognize that
every day might give us that opportunity
maybe we won't be so hard on ourselves
about how we're not my life is
meaningless and that's what I hope
people get out of this book all right
the book is the next person you meet in
heaven and you help them thanks very
much wrong with us here in the toyota
green related